in this lesson we're going to talk about
expected value so what is expected value
what's the formula what does it mean how
do we solve problems that ask for us to
find the expected value that's what
we're going to talk about in this lesson
so first of all this is the formula here
that you can memorize
basically what it is is you take the
outcome okay which i'm just denoting as
x sub i
the probability that that outcome occurs
that's p of x sub i
and what you're doing is you're
multiplying those together
and then what you're doing is you're
summing up all of those products of the
outcome and the probability that outcome
occurs
okay so that's a mouthful but basically
what you're looking at is what's the
expected value
over time if you run a number of
experiments what would you expect to get
on average
over a long period of trials or time
let's do a simple example say you roll
like a number cube okay
one through six right
and you say well what's the expected
value if i roll this number cube well
you can obviously get a one two three
four five or six okay so those are the
outcomes the probability of getting a
one would be one chance out of six right
assuming it's all well balanced and
whatnot probably getting a 2 is 1 6 and
so on right so what we're going to do is
we're going to multiply the probability
of the outcome times the outcome so
that's going to be 1 times 1 6 which is
1 6 2 times 1 6 which is 2 6.
3 times 1 6 is 3 6 4 times 1 6 is 4 6 5
times 1 6 is 5 6 and 6 times 1 6 is 6 6
okay and if we add all these together
what do we get well we get 3
6 which equals
3 and 3 6 which is three and one-half so
what we would expect on average
you know over a long number of rolls of
this die that the
expected value or the average outcome is
going to be three and a half okay so
that's the idea so let's do a more uh
typical example here as could be seen on
the act right
example one so go ahead and do this on
your own pause the video we'll go
through it together but here it says
given the probability distribution what
is the expected value and you can see
here's the outcomes and here's the
probability
that they occur
so what we're going to do is we're going
to multiply them together so 5 times
0.10 is
0.50 10 times 0.50 is
5.0
20 times 0.40 is
8.0 okay if we add these up you can see
we're getting 13.5
divided by
okay
i'm sorry not divided by 13.5 which is
that our expected value and you can see
that
you know it makes sense because here you
have like about a 50 chance that you're
going to get a 10. a 40 chance you're
going to get a 20. not much chance only
10 percent that you're going to get a 5
you would expect that's going to be
somewhere in between 10 and 20 and
that's the expected value 13.5 all we
had to do was sum up those products of
the outcome and the probability of the
outcome so expected value there you have
it